سيدي الرئيس ، أنا دقيق
لقد أسيء فهمي بالفعل
قال أنه يمكننا التلاعب به
أقول أن كل شيء سيكون على ما يرام
من فضلك استمر في الحديث عن أن
تحدث الممثل الروسي عن ذلك
أنه لا توجد قيم وطنية
عاصفة رعدية في النهاية لا أحد
جمع هو ولدي من بلدي
قال رأي إذا كنت أجنبي في
تبدو روسيا ثم أطلب كثيرا
ربما أصلح ما يتحدث عن روسيا
knotless الآن قانونيًا تمامًا 19
هذا هو الامتثال للقانون الدولي
جلبت للعائلات
هذا هو حفظ السلام
[موسيقى]
إنهم يمثلون قيم الأمة و
أنت الآن نازي
إنهم يمثلون القيم الأسرية
تماما الكيمياء وهم يمثلون
قيم التكامل الإيمان
dievini ولهذا السبب يمكنهم ذلك
ربما تفهم لماذا أنا
فوجئت أن الروسي
سأل ممثلو عن قيمهم
إذا كنت من الخارج
يحدد
شكرا لك شكرا لك على
شكرا على الترجمة
إنه لمن دواعي سروري أن أكون قادرًا على ذلك
[تصفيق]